we're getting one more sign that efforts
to control inflation are working for the
first time in more than a year the
Federal Reserve met and decided not to
raise interest rates yesterday although
the FED chairman made it clear that
future rate hikes are still likely so
let's bring in CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger AKA dollar dollar Jill
y'all so let's get right into it
um why did the Federal Reserve pause
raising interest rates you know we just
got a CPI consumer price index report
out and it did show a lot of progress on
inflation so if you remember inflation
peaked last June at a 9.1 percent rate
and now we learned we're at four percent
now that's still two times what the FED
really wants right but I think the FED
said look after 15 months 10 consecutive
rate hikes time to pause and see how
higher rates are impacting the rest of
the economy so they said we're going to
chill out this time okay how long would
this pause possibly be I mean the we
have to look at this and be realistic
the next meeting isn't the end of July
so that's a live meeting we could see
another rate increase at that time maybe
they wait till the end there's four more
meetings by the end of the year the FED
projects that we could see two more rate
hikes before the end of the year okay as
soon as the announcement happened Mark
the tumbled a little bit a little Panic
for some yeah why well you know I just
said the FED projected that there could
be another half of a percentage Point
increase by the end of the year markets
had thought or investors had thought it
would just be one they thought oh
there'll be a quarter of a percentage
point before the end of the year it was
two they panicked can I just be clear
about something the FED makes these
projections they're not always right
there you go you know they know they are
human beings there's a ton of different
people working on this they have all the
information but this is an economy that
has defied expectations there's human
error involved absolutely all right so
uh the FED has been raising interest
rates to fight inflation have they been
successful in your opinion well I think
been successful and that we have seen it
go from 9.1 to 4 percent but to be clear
there is still work to do prices are
still high especially on the service
side of the economy right about that
right eggs can come down in price pretty
quickly gas can come down but when you
go get a haircut or you go hire your CPA
their prices are not coming down all
right so real quick the FED has been
raising these interest rates
aggressively but there's a fear that the
raise could turn into a dip into
recession
do you think that's a possibility it's
always a possibility I want to be clear
there is no recession right now at all
so for everyone sitting at home rate
hikes are still in play you need to be
very careful about managing your debt
pay down that credit card debt put that
money in high interest savings be
careful prepare for the worst and hope
for the best all right we were talking
during a commercial break that you're
headed to the spa well deserved you're
one of the hardest working people I know
just let you know we appreciate you